hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to let's play The House 2 I
thought it was only finishing fitting
that I finished the other one as well
because I'm that kind of guy so let's
get to it the legend has it that there
is a house in a small town that has been
closed and left empty for decades the
house belonged to a wealthy family but
then one day all family members father
mother daughter and the maid that's not
family man what is it the Brady punch
committed suicide from that time the
neighbors have closed the house for good
as I believe of the house where all
family committed suicide is cursed some
said that they have heard a woman
screaming a woman's screaming voice from
that house yet no one dare to enter the
house are you are you dare okay let's
go okay I won't skip the intro come on
bring it on what do you got for me get
inside okie dokie DK oh that's not a
good start d d DK I'm so strong Prime
off with my hands
no there we go almost there we go oh
just by the pure strength of my knocking
I must really want to die if I'm going
yes I'm now inside the house thank you
very much loading
[Music]
ah this looks somewhat
familiar okay sorry the bottom is cut up
on there a bit I couldn't quite get the
screen reaching right but it just says
living room bathroom bedroom working
room safe room that's all it says down
there hopefully you guys won't miss too
much more I can feel something strange
in this house I actually feel it since
the first day I came to the work here as
a nursaid I'm so afraid of that thing
should I quit oh yeah yeah stupid idiot
oh this oh
God what is wrong with that one what's
wrong with all these people look very
weird Okay looks like a body thing there
all right o
hello nope clicky clicky all right I'm
just going to do the same thing I did in
the first one which you cck the same
things over and over again till
something
happens like that puffs of smoke
huh oh
[Music]
hello oh no it's a
haunted
house click
click I must be some kind of a badass if
I just Walt my way in here
who e get that blood out of here nobody
wants that jeez wait what's
that what the hell is going on you
okay these do eventually get a little
creepy but that's okay I can handle it
I'm so brave anyway look at me like a
boss come on come on come on must be
something that I'm not clicking
[Music]
here you [__] you [__]
all right daughter's year of birth okay
I got to remember the daughter's year of
birth what is
it what is it what's the daughter's year
of
birth I I don't know what it
is a God damn
it [__]
hell golly Jesus she's
not she's not she's not
I don't know daughter's year of birth
okay I got to remember the daughter's
year of
birth okay I will admit this sequel is
much creepier than the second one or the
first
one what else am I need to click she's
not all right anything else going to
jump out at
me okay it doesn't look like
it ah [__] hell God stop it
[Laughter]
jeez this one's got a lot of
jumps hey it's the bathroom again water
flushy flushy of
Bible there's got to be something behind
there isn't there oh I can already feel
that one
coming clicking click fast who's there
come on in just taking a quick
shower Brit's never hurt
nobody okay some things aren't clicking
anymore ah didn't scare me didn't scare
me like a rock not scar oh
blood big [__] seen that
before boy looking to wait those blood
stains there before probably not who's
in there who's there oh I
no I am truly sorry for what I have done
to our kid please forgive me not
forgiven punishment is
toast anybody know what I'm talking
about please tell me there's someone
that knows what I was talking about the
punishment is toast no no one I bet no
one ah he wait a minute where're who
that oh they're really there I was
expecting it to not be there but it is
exactly
there okay then that's a little weird oh
that better not be
there hello come on
in
God they definitely slow on the
pace just clicking around randomly
though feels like I'm just clicking
aimlessly have I missed anything that
needs to be clicked I don't think
so I'm not sure it's just like I'm
clicking random things until something
happens I wish there was a point to
it hi come
in I don't know I don't know
oh
okay less jump scares in that
one oh this looks good I love the kids
room let's
see diploma of freaking everybody the
out
golly cing on things nothing happening
ah there we go certificate of possession
Nicole a demon body was officially
possessed oh year of her birth Wait no
that's not a year of her birth 1963 is
the year of adoption not
birth I remember it anyway 1963 okay so
the
[Music]
parents so the parents made a
significant
Mistake by
adop why did I come
here
[Music]
why oh hello she comes every night well
that's fantastic she loves playing
hide-and-seek oh good to know he really
good in hiding I never find it okay
fantastic why are little kids so scary
good God what is this about little kids
they're supposed to be happy and
adorable
these people are
[Music]
terrifying play with me
okay
okay I like to play I'll play a game
with
you play with
me still clicking still clicking
aimlessly flip plop fpop flip plop Flip
Flip Flip
[Music]
okay okay I still don't know if
anything's actually supposed to happen
or what I don't think there's anything
left to
click oh there we go oh who is that
there were not two daughters
before
ring okay all right hi get out of here
we're
closed okay I've clicked on everything
else so I'm assuming that stuff's
about oh God Jesus Christ get away from
me oh you loading screen
[Applause]
[__]
Flip
Flip poison nitric
acid this actually look familiar to the
house
one oh I see that hang on I see
that ah birth 1947 is her birth 1947
1947 remember
that hello hi
I don't know if it's like on a timer or
what or if it's just you know after you
click enough things generally start to
happen
uhoh
1947 oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh okay there we go we're
on oh what is that a beehive on your
head okay I think I should probably get
out of the house now this is where I
would go
home yes
poison all right what if he going to
come alive and jump at
me
[Applause]
hide in the dark and under the bed
1947 I can't hide in the dark under the
bed in the dark under the bed is that a
clue or
something oh oh okay seriously what is
wrong with your face what is going on
there like
a yeah in the dark and under the deed
okay oh h ah hey how about that flip
ploop can I go to the safe room
now so that was a clue hide in the dark
in under the bed so I got the key to the
safe room can I go 1947
1947 Flip Flip Flip Flip Flip Flip Flop
Flip Flip Flop oh flip flop come on
let's get something happening let's get
the hippity hoppity
happening
hello hello is anybody home does anybody
want to do anything about
this oh hello hello don't turn the light
on thank you I can't stand to see you
suffer like this anymore rest in peace
my poor child that's not
[Music]
good okay so uh now
what
yeah okay now what what is going to
happen What
woo 1947
woo dad is a dead looking
baby gravy what did
do F in the dark and on out the
bed
[Music]
1947 I can connect the
dots no how
lovely anything else
okay why why I have to die mom I want to
live no matter
what okay
that's oh
[Music]
what
was
okay darken under your bed I get it I
get it I get it okay can I go home now I
have I don't know what I got I got
pretty
oh go
away who is playing with all oh no oh oh
don't show me your face don't don't I
don't understand it you're probably ugly
I mean you're probably beautiful but
don't show
meway
click oh
no yep ugly
ugly all right I I found a key to this
special room
oh what's the special
[Music]
room how was that the key that I found I
don't know what's a special
room
say tell me
[Music]
more okay apparently nothing's going to
happen oh
okay well I guess that's it we're all
done now seriously what's going
on okay anyway I don't know what that
was all about but apparently bug M or
something I don't know so anyway that's
all that I have here thank you all so
much for watching click the annotations
for more videos that I've done and as
always if you got suggestions let me
know in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video
bye-bye a